a ukrainian military official says
russia is preparing for the next stage
of its offensive after moscow ordered
its forces to step up military
operations while most fighting is taking
place in the east russian rockets and
missiles are also pounding cities far
from the front lines keeve says the
attacks have killed dozens of people in
recent days
destruction in the central ukrainian
city knee pro
where a russian missile has left a
gaping hole in a residential street
ukrainian officials say three people
were killed and 15 wounded
our windows were sealed with duct tape
but when the shock wave came some shards
of glass still hit me i was likely
wounded on my left side
the street is home to the uzmash
industrial plant
the russian defense ministry says the
factory was producing parts for
ballistic missiles making it a
legitimate military target
there was a strike just around the
corner next to ushmash
then i saw a video
was on fire and there were explosions
many fled after the attack
nipro's mayor urged residents on
facebook to leave
saying it was dangerous to remain
in ukraine's northeast three people were
killed in a rocket attack here
local authorities say a school and
several homes were hit
a factory destroyed in the harbor city
of odessa far to the west away from the
front military experts predict an
increase in russian strikes as the war
of attrition grinds on
all right well let's go to dw's nick
spicer who is in the ukrainian capital
kiev hi nick good to see you so ukraine
says russia is preparing for the next
stage of its offensive in ukraine have
officials actually indicated what
they're expecting from russian forces
uh no president zielinski has
acknowledged that even the russians
themselves have said the operational
pause is over and they're going to
resume offensive operations but he said
that we will endure we will win and we
will rebuild our lives but beyond that
no indication as to what the ukrainians
are expecting but it's not hard to
imagine what will occur it's already
happening rolling artillery barrages of
the kind we've seen over these past few
months where thousands sometimes 50 000
shells are fired in a day destroying
towns entirely where ukrainian defenders
are holed up causing them to repeat
retreat strategically take up defensive
positions elsewhere perhaps more missile
attacks striking civilian targets
although the russians will say
there were military personnel within
those buildings so more of the same to a
certain extent paolo
now how well positioned is ukraine to
defend itself and hold off the russian
advance nick
well things have changed in the past 10
days with or two weeks let's say with
the arrival of western weaponry so far
the american highmars precision and
mobile rocket system has really tipped
the balance in certain areas
they're shoot and scoot vehicles they
can fire six rockets with an accuracy of
one to three meters and what the
ukrainians are using them for is to take
out giant ammunition depots to stop
those artillery barrages that have been
destroying the country basically uh they
destroyed about 20 of them and the
russians have the particularity of
really having large weapon depots and
not spreading out their artillery shells
as other armies will do keeping them
near the rail heads and so considerable
success in the ukrainian side and stuff
we don't even hear about there's an
underground for instance in here son
in that city which is occupied by the
russians but where the people are
unhappy about the occupation russian
soldiers will wake up and see uh hand
bills posted on the building saying
sleep tight the high mars are arriving
thanks nick for that update dw's nick
spicer in kiev
you